there's a few things that favor Sean  O'Malley in this fight and the UFC knows  what they're doing they're not throwing  Sean O'Malley to the [ __ ] wolves here  he can win this fight he can win this  fight  um it's tough to pick him to win the  fight but I'm gonna do it I I think I'm  gonna go on a limb here and think even  though he's another dog I think shot  O'Malley the lights can't get bright  enough for him you can't give him enough  attention he's almost like a uh a Conor  McGregor in that aspect or a uh a Paul  brother where you can't get big enough  you're not going to scare them they do  better the more lights and cameras that  are on him it's just what he was born to  do